Andrés muy buenos días efectivamente
estamos A pocas horas de que termine el
título 42 a las 11:59 de esta noche del
jueves hora del este y desde ya el
gobierno de los Estados Unidos ha
desplegado los 1.500 soldados que había
prometido el presidente Joe biden Para
apoyar las patrullas fronterizas así
como también se han desplegado agentes
de aduanas agentes de asilo que apoyen
los centros de detención migratoria en
las diferentes ciudades estadounidenses
que comparten frontera con México como
brownswell Laredo El Paso Texas que es
la ciudad que colinda aquí con Ciudad
Juárez o por ejemplo San Diego con
Tijuana y es que Se presume que muchos
de los migrantes están esperando a que
termine el título 42 para cruzar la
frontera de manera irregular es decir no
lo harían por los puentes
internacionales donde están las oficinas
de aduanas y no lo harían a través de
los puntos ciegos algunos de ellos
emplazados En el muro metálico por donde
podrían llegar a cruzar y una vez
pisando suelo estadounidense entregarse
a los agentes o todas las patrullas para
ser llevados a estos centros de
detención migratoria y allí solicitar el
asilo el problema ahora radica es para
los migrantes que no son de nacionalidad
Mexicana con la nueva reglamentación que
puso sobre la mesa Joe biden esta semana
y es la de que le negará el asilo a
todas aquellas nacionalidades que han
cruzado diferentes fronteras para llegar
a los Estados Unidos y esto pondría en
graves aprietos a todos los migrantes
suramericanos Centroamericanos africanos
y del Caribe Andrés Ustedes han podido
hablar con los migrantes que están
acampando allí a un costado del puente
internacional que conecta la ciudad
Juárez con el paso en Texas que tanto
influye para los migrantes en el final
del título 42 que dicen ellos
Bueno ayer cayendo la noche logramos
hablar con muchos de los migrantes que
están acampando al lado de este puente y
también frente al centro de detención
migratoria que se incendió el pasado 27
de marzo y donde murieron 40 migrantes
esto es a pocos metros del muro metálico
que separa Ciudad Juárez con El Paso
Texas para la mayoría de estos migrantes
de nacionalidad venezolana es peor
incluso que se termine el título 42
porque lo que ellos tienen entendido es
que si cruzan irregularmente el título
42 los deporta inmediatamente al mismo
país de procedencia es decir en este
caso México los deja muchos de ellos se
encuentran varados en un limbo
burocrático migratorio aquí en México
mientras que lo que tienen entendido es
que con el título ocho serían deportados
si su si su solicitud de asilo no es
aprobada al país de origen es decir a
Venezuela para ellos esto es un gran
temor porque han cruzado siete países y
no quieren devolverse a su país natal de
manera que están haciendo todos los
trámites legales por la vía correcta y
esto es a través de la aplicación
en donde solicitan una cita para exponer
su caso en el caso de los venezolanos es
alegar que en su país se ha instalado
una dictadura que no los ha dejado
trabajar que los ha intimidado y de esta
manera poder vivir en los Estados Unidos